turning now to an important part of our
nation's history a new documentary
series explores president president
abraham lincoln's legacy lincoln's
dilemma is narrated by actor jeffrey
white the four-part series explores the
life and times of president lincoln
through never before heard stories from
historians and scholars and rare
archival material it challenges the
perception of who he was and his complex
journey to end slavery in america this
preview clip examines lincoln's second
inaugural address to the nation
in it and he does this moral calculation
which i think is an astonishing
sentence for
any white person to have said in 1865
all the more so for a head of state
we may have to suffer
as much violence as we have inflicted on
these people
in order to persevere as a nation
and if that happens
the judgments of god are right and just
award-winning journalist jelani cobb is
an executive producer for lincoln's
dilemma he joins us now with historian
and author kelly carter jackson who is
also featured in the series good morning
to you both thank you for joining us
thank you um jelani i'll start with the
beautiful voice by the way
i have to get that out the way beautiful
writer as well yeah and i heard that
while i was watching the doctor's series
um most people think they know president
lincoln's history i mean whether they
were taught it in school or read
afterwards what did this docu-series aim
to set straight well i mean there's so
much about lincoln you just there's
layers and layers and layers and so we
know what we did what he did we don't
necessarily know why he did it or how he
did it or how he came to the decisions
that he made and more importantly we
know very little about the context
generally speaking yeah the context in
which those decisions were made the cast
of characters the different
forces that were seeking to influence
him and particularly the the i think one
of the things we do best in this film is
look at the interplay the relationship
between frederick douglass consistently
pushing abraham lincoln and lincoln
negotiating and moving toward what he
ultimately does in issuing the
emancipation proclamation
yeah i i be in the beginning of this you
you go directly to january 6th and i'm
curious
how you saw that play
a part in this story of lincoln and his
dilemma i mean when you think of the
civil war when you think of the country
at odds
um this is the period in history that
people point to as sort of the precedent
for understanding you know things like
january 6 and civil unrest and political
unrest so there's a lot of resonance
within the documentary and i think the
wonderful thing about history is that
it's such a template or roadmap for
understanding not just where we've been
but where we might go
and i think this documentary does a good
job at showing like what is possible
yeah i hope it doesn't come to a civil
war again absolutely right exactly but
it is a it is a good lesson that we've
been through worse and we can't get
through this uh going back to lincoln
one of the things i thought was
fascinating is the the idea that he's
the great emancipator this was not a
nickname that he welcomed politically
and something you talk about kelly yeah
he is not the great emancipator and he
he pushed back on that idea himself you
know scholars for decades have really
been saying that the enslaved freed
themselves um that they had to get to
union lines they had to run away they
had to take the agency to do it
themselves and so lincoln says over and
over again i did not for you god made
you free yeah um and i think that's so
important because we only sort of know
lincoln by that one-liner lincoln greet
the slaves yeah and it's it's so much
more um complicated and nuanced than
that and lincoln also had some other
ideas after the slaves were freed about
what to do with with integrating the
country joanna you want to take that one
i mean he followed a really torturous
path you know because initially he
believed in in the early versions of the
emancipation proclamation were paired
with this idea that the free black
population would then be
sent out of the country
and they had various ideas about where
this p where these people could go and
people flirted with the idea of sending
all of the freed blacks to haiti uh and
over time and of course this is going
back to the dialogue with frederick
douglass he came comes to understand
that this is not workable and that these
people are a foundational part of what
the united states is when we have to
clear some sort of path for them to be
included there are so many layers to
this docu-series it's beautifully done
and beautifully told
the fate of democracy hanging in the
balance um abraham lincoln trying to
make both sides happy um but i want to
get back to something you said you
mentioned it being a road map
i couldn't help but to draw parallels to
exactly what is going on right now and i
almost thought
we're taking a u-turn because what we
have been going through over the last
couple of years
it's almost like you can take it and put
it over the picture of the past and just
trace it was that a huge part of this
docu-series to remind americans where we
could be headed if we don't find a way
to get on the same page yeah i think you
know not to be alarmist or anything like
that but i do think that the past should
be a cautionary tale for all of us it
should show us
where we have been and how we got down
this horrible road um but also how we
can work to make it better and i think
one of the things that is so great about
lincoln is that he responded to the
people he listened to frederick douglass
he took on you know the wisdom and the
guidance that other people were giving
him to really try to live up to these
ideas of what it means to have an
american democracy and american freedom
for all people yeah
i was just going to say the lincoln of
the debates was it very different
very different
by the time you know of the emancipation
and the end of the civil war
but one of the greatest things about
abraham lincoln is that he evolved with
his time
and there are certainly contradictory
things there are things that he says in
1858 that are outright white supremacist
in those debates with stephen douglas
and
you see him
the reason he's such an intriguing
figure that we've never gotten tired of
talking about him is that he is learning
and evolving and taking in new
information and coming to question his
own assumptions
and it's because he has to do this in
front of an entire nation but i so hope
that that is still possible today
exactly exactly our point that that is
what's most encouraging to me is that
lincoln was responsive to the people on
the ground to the enslaved people
themselves that were literally setting
the agenda i mean frederick douglass
says this is a war of abolition this is
not just about bringing the south back
into the country this is about ending
the institution of slavery born into
slavery and then has the ear of a
president it's an amazing story in its
own right and yeah learning and evolving
is something we all should do uh jelani
cobb and kelly carter jackson thank you
so much thank you the four-part
docu-series lincoln's dilemma premieres
tomorrow on apple tv plus it is great
trust me you should watch it can't wait
to see the rest of it